millones de personas regresan a casa
para celebrar el año nuevo lunar chino
en la mayor migración de personas del
mundo precisamente cuando llega el fin
de las restricciones por la pandemia Los
viajeros tienen sentimientos encontrados
ya han pasado tres años del covid en
este tiempo creo que todos nos hemos
acostumbrado al ritmo de todos los
procedimientos como las pruebas para
detectarlo o el uso de mascarillas las
bombas Así que nos acostumbramos a esa
vida y ahora de repente con todo lo que
se abre la verdad es que no me siento
tan emocionado
algunos a pesar de la crisis económica
que ha causado daños de cierre en China
saldrán a ver a sus familiares
por culpa del sueldo no ha sido tan alto
y a veces ni siquiera voy a trabajar y
después de todos estos dos o tres años
intentando salir adelante en shadojay ya
que no he estado en casa durante tres
años ahora que se han levantado las
restricciones del covid quería estar con
mi no importa si tengo dinero o no
quiero ir a verlos
hasta el miércoles 480 millones de
personas se habían desplazado por todo
el país desde el 7 de enero las
autoridades estiman que hasta febrero se
realizarán más de 2.000 millones de
desplazamientos el presidente
intentó mantener su política de cero
covid con duras restricciones a la
movilidad y confinamientos pero una
serie de protestas entre noviembre y
diciembre lo obligaron a dar marcha
atrás y ahora dice estar preocupado por
el posible aumento de los casos debido a
la masiva migración tras años de un
supuesto subregistro de muertes por el
Coby 19 china reveló el sábado que
60.000 personas murieron por el virus en
el último mes